>> Android’s native webkit browser enables
users to experience the full web and receive
a complete set of functionality that integrates
web viewing with other parts of the mobile
phone. Start the web browser by pressing the
browser icon in the home screen. Let's search
for info on a cool movie, War Games. You can
enter a URL, search the web, visit a bookmark,
download images for your wallpaper, and much
more. If you’d like to link a photo to a
contact’s profile, you can long press on
that photo after downloading it. By selecting
and holding an item on the touch screen, you
uncover an additional set of actions. Select
save image, then choose download history where
you can select that image. Press menu and
select set as, then select contact icon. Here,
you can either create new contact or grab
the image and place it into one of your existing
contacts. Say you want to share that great
picture of your parents. With Android, you
can easily cut and paste between all applications,
long press and select paste to place that
Flicker link into the email. The same full
web experience are used too on a computer
can be found on Android.